[Music]
welcome back to Road reactions I'm your
host Sandra Bullock I got one suggestion
from the last Road reaction episode one
on tech leads filibuster technique and
that was guilfoyle because everyone
keeps telling me I look like guilfoyle
[Music]
and I was thinking yeah
maybe and then something happened today
that made me decide yeah really
I saw guilfoyle in a thumbnail and I
actually thought it was one of my videos
for a moment because I thought it was
speaking true story
sounds like up that that's a sign now I
actually have to do the video I legit
just thought hey I'm being recommended
one of my videos which can happen
because I have like you know my personal
channel and I subscribe to my channel so
I thought it was that but it wasn't it
was actually guilfoyle so I guess I do
look look like I'm because I I had
myself tricked and lovely with this new
fancy 1992 haircut we can get some good
memes
alright so we're gonna we're gonna just
look up guilfoyle so I'm gonna react to
guilfoyle we're gonna watch one of these
and I'll just give my opinion or say
what I'm gonna say I guess from my robe
guilfoyle verse HR part 1 doctor work
Bertram while I have you you don't have
me so I'll give the patron izing tone
I'm more concerned with being right than
being fast and I don't like dealing with
people too
oh god this does sound like me wit are
we done you're that guy what guy I'm
assigning you five coders inadvisable
noted I'll send them over first thing
tomorrow all right I guess I don't have
much to say I don't know what am I
supposed am I supposed to say if you're
going to throw five randoms under me at
least let me pick my team am I like
cause this am i some kind of embodiment
of guilfoyle or is he an embodiment of
me I might actually be older than this
guy good to place go you know that I
don't even know the guy I just get told
I look like oh well actually you know
what it only happened on YouTube in real
life I got called Jesus a lot people
would always call me Jesus so I guess
that was fine too I was lying out
whatever I guess as long as you remember
me that's better than not I would just
pretend to be jeez it's just for for the
giggles and if someone called me it how
would be like that was get me a drink or
something you know is this your new team
it is five people as you requested every
other that guy accepted their
limitations took on a team and managed
to get their work done some of them this
a Bitcoin mining rig over here a cryptic
coin my yeah that's something I would
totally do just build a computer and a
crate not anymore though cases are cheap
my now billionaires none of them would
have gotten it I did once have a crypto
farm and it was a took up half of a room
to a dick measuring contest with HR when
they were two weeks behind
so lucky us I guess your unique user
guilfoyle you said that I had to choose
you said I could have a fast or I could
have it right but I just got it fast and
right and all I had to do was threaten
your manhood by assigning you other
coders it worked in seven other
companies and it obviously worked here
we're back on schedule now why would I
be sorry about that
I respect your skills thank you see you
in the morning
all right I really don't have a whole
lot to say about this do I look like
guilfoyle
not anymore I cut my hair shave my beard
now I'm Sandra Bullock 1992 speed with
Keanu Reeves look I know that was not
very exciting let me at least react to
the one that got me you know again get
me churning thinking no this this is me
I thought I thought this is me let's go
back into this mode okay
so I guess I makes sense to react to
something with actually a little code or
hacking in it cuz the last one yeah I
didn't really have anything to say I
pretty much just watched the whole thing
it was boring
well boring for commentating I agree i
still find it hilarious because i love
this show
alright let's let's have react to this
one this one guilfoyle hacks jinyang
smart fridge this along this wall
this'll warm this warm this one just
pointing out every single one that's
like something a kid like a really young
kid would do it this one's bought this
once one it's and I know I got no kid I
get it if you have if you have kids
you'd understand
the refrigerator's broken the ice cream
is a male team
let me guess is it because it's warm yes
fine
I'll call the repairman and he'll come
here and fix it posthaste
no I want a new fridge a smarter fridge
a smarter fridge well like this fourteen
thousand fourteen thousand dollar fridge
for a smart fridge unlike you I now work
for a little that's thrill expensive
fridge 14s on my fridge how hard can it
be I don't know I guess you'd have to
know a lot about embedded systems to
really get all the controls in there but
fourteen thousand dollars
I feel like do it for less oh well you
know it's not much to say about that I'm
wondering now though how much is a
fridge cost three thousand to three
thousand two thousand to four thousand
okay that's a lot less than fourteen
thousand that's you know that's just a
little ballpark okay it's good let's
continue myself so he's a hacking this
is supposedly him hacking into Iran but
that was a brand of the fridge didn't
some it's got a little tiny bit of code
there it's like a variable and what one
switch statement it's not much he can do
with that right unless he's pulled in
from a library or something I don't know
you're sitting here trying to hack
jinyang spaz but instead of doing your
actual work good luck it's a ten digit
alphanumeric look I mean you have one
underpowered laptop saying you know you
should have the answer in nine thousand
years nine thousand years it's time to
pull out the big gun the big gun I think
that's Anton maybe you should pull out
the bug gun
so he's in here he's hooking up - is he
open up there like their mainframe
processor stuff block version whatever
guilfoyle second version to add hat okay
it's freakin Java public static void
main string args face wrecking recog
face equals new face raw recog actions
action list equals new actions string
stored cash equals cash stored faces
debug matching names
I don't know I'm reading this like it's
actually a thing action list calendar
update weather update owner - tagged
owner detect shopping list owner text
YouTube wait there's a YouTube hash
there should we look it up as it is d
capital q w4 w 9 capital W G X capital X
C capital Q alright let's see what this
is on you what we got what are we gonna
get beautiful beautiful that's what that
is death it's pretty freakin cool
all right so now Jennings going back to
ass bridge my call frame hello you
attack means right here doing it it's
watching him Anna you misspelled my name
I did I had to overclock Anton but I was
able to brute-force the backdoor
password to that all right so he did it
with Anton and we got rickrolled okay
all right I'm out I don't even know if I
can release this stay safe out there
guys and maybe I'll do a real video soon
[Music]
[Music]